so the number one question that I that I
hear when I travel around the country
and I meet people at speaking events and
that kind of thing by far without a
doubt the number one question I get is
how do you deal with all the hatred
I guess people have noticed that I tend
to attract quite a bit of vitriol and
hatred a lot of people don't like me and
they're very eager to let me know that
they don't like me and to let me know
every day all day constantly and in very
strong terms
now bring out the violin and I'll tell
you more of my sad tale no I I mean I'm
not the only one I probably attract a
higher volume of it than most people
just by the nature of what I do for a
living but I'm certainly not the only
one I'm sure you have noticed this is
well in your own life that if you try to
speak any kind of truth whatsoever
people are going to come after you and
you're gonna deal with it online and in
the real world and I assume that when
people ask me this question the reason I
get it so often is that people are
looking for insights they can use in
their own life not because they want to
hear my life story so I'm gonna try
usually when I'm asked this question the
answer that I provide is I think
unsatisfactory because I just I'm put on
the spot but now that I've had time to
think about it I want to try to answer
it again and I think the first thing
that we have to do if we're gonna talk
about how to deal with the hatred from
the world the backlash that you get from
defending your belief system first thing
we have to do is reiterate again and
understand and embrace and accept that
it absolutely will happen you will get
this hatred we know this we know it from
our own personal experience we also know
it from Scripture Jesus warns us about
this repeatedly and his warning
certainly apply to our culture probably
more than most but they do apply to all
cultures throughout time now
true but on the on the other hand and so
it seems almost counterintuitive because
we also are a culture of indifference
people are lazy apathetic indifferent
and you would think if you didn't know
any better that one of the advantages of
living in a lazy apathetic and different
culture is that you can say and do
whatever you want and nobody will pay
attention or care because they're all
too busy watching their five hours of TV
a day and they're online and there you
know obsessed with the movies and video
games and everything and they're too
immersed in that world to even care what
you're saying and that is true most of
the time most of the time you can say
what you want and do what you want and
nobody will care
because part of that that's why so many
people will will say you know let people
do what they want as long as they're not
hurting me it's fine and they feel like
that's some sort of virtuous moral code
to live by so I don't you know as long
as they're not hurting me I don't care I
let people live live and let live right
but everyone who really lives according
to that motto it's just pure laziness on
their part it's just because they don't
care it's not it's not like this is not
some virtuous restraint on their part
they really just don't care about
anything or anyone and they just want to
watch TV that's what that means
but here's a problem
these people the average American who is
living in this deluded world and is just
entertaining himself into oblivion and I
do believe this applies to the average
American I know I'm taking a dim view of
the average American but I'm sorry I
think it's the reality this is how the
average American works but floating
along on the current don't care about
anything and they're just staring at
screens not ever taking even a moment to
really think about anything the only
thing they're thinking about is what's
the next show I'm gonna watch when can I
get my video in the next video game what
am I gonna eat you know that's what they
care about and that's what they're
thinking about
so
to live in this world
and luxury and entertainment and moral
numbness in order to really live in that
world you cannot accept any truth every
truth in your life has to become your
own version of that truth because the
truth has a hard edge you know and once
you inject truth into your life well
then now you have to kind of start
conforming yourself around it and and
you can't live entirely according to
your own whims so if you want to live
that way you must in the end reject all
truth and we're seeing this play out in
our culture
so people that are in this fog of
indifference
if you come in and you inject any truth
into that fog doesn't matter what it is
if you introduce any truth
that's when they're gonna detach
themselves from the screen for long
enough to devour you and rip you to
pieces and then go back to what they
were doing before
when you threaten this indifferent lazy
life that they're living which is the
only thing they really care about when
you threaten that
when you interfere with it
that's when they come after
when you criticize when you when you
cause them to look at themselves in the
mirror when you criticize their precious
sacred lifestyle because these days
that's the one thing you're never
allowed to do right you anything can be
justified as long as it's my lifestyle I
can say well this is my lifestyle it's
how I choose to live so you can't
criticize it
I can criticize it because I think it's
wrong just because it's a choice that
you've personally made well it's a
personal choice so that means it's right
no I mean a lot of personal choices are
wrong and I think it's wrong so I'm
gonna tell you I think it's wrong I'm
sorry but once you take that attitude in
that approach that's when they will
descend upon you
and so then the hatred is inevitable in
that case and it's going to be very very
vicious
so how do you handle it how do I handle
it well the honest answer is I have
historically handled it very very poorly
I have to admit I'm trying to do better
I'm working on it but I have handled it
poorly and I but I have found through
trial and error that there are three
serious mistakes you can make when
dealing with the hatred of the world and
I have made all these mistakes so let's
talk about the mistakes first the first
mistake is the obvious one the first
mistake is to take it personally and to
be offended by it and hurt we should
never allow ourselves to be personally
offended by the sniping and the vitriol
from the world
particularly when that windows personal
attacks come because you said something
true never take a person it's illogical
anyway because when someone comes after
you and says the most awful things about
you it's not personal now it may be
about you you know on the surface what
they're saying may be personal and they
may be talking about you on the surface
but really it's not they don't care
about you it doesn't matter what you you
don't matter it's what you said that
they hate it's your belief system it's
the conviction it's the thing that you
said the position that you took that's
what they hate and because they're too
lazy and they lack the intelligence and
the energy to engage the belief system
itself they will instead take the lazy
shortcut approach and attack the person
who holds the belief because that's the
easiest thing to do they don't want to
apply their minds at all or expend the
energy required to listen to what you're
saying and then try to refute it so
instead they'll they'll listen for long
enough to understand that they disagree
and then they'll just they'll just try
to rip you apart
personally maybe bring your family into
it whatever they can do to hurt you
and shut you down and make you afraid
and then they can go back to what they
were doing before I will admit that I
made this mistake early on when I first
started doing this when I first gained
an audience online and I was giving my
opinions to a relatively large group of
people the first couple of times that I
experienced a massive blowback at
backlash for something that I said well
you know it's hundreds and thousands of
people that are attacking you there's
hate mail and there's comments
everywhere and it's just
all times I'll admit that I was
overwhelmed and and I did let it get to
me and I read some of the comments and I
did take them personally
supposed to admit this but I did earlier
it's it's it's a difficult thing you
know when you're when you're not used to
it it can be very hard
I made that mistake don't make that
mistake second mistake is on the
opposite end of the spectrum the second
mistake is to enjoy the hatred
there are people that they get the
hatred the blowback and their first
reaction is to recoil from it and to be
kind of afraid of it and that's that's
normal now we have to overcome that
reaction but it's a normal human
reaction but then there's the people who
and these are internet trolls basically
this is this is this is what ends up a
person like this with this reaction
could eventually become an internet
troll an infamous internet troll that's
someone who thrives on the negative
attention and likes it there are a lot
of people in the pundit commentator
class conservatives and liberals who
that's that's the case for them they
really like to be hated because it's a
tension it is it's
a lot of very energetic attention
directed at them and they like that
now me I've also made this mistake
at the beginning
experience the blowback I was
overwhelmed I was I was taking it
personally and so then I thought well
the best defense mechanism is to try to
like it somehow
and so I tried that as a defense
mechanism to shield myself I tried to
put on this thing of you know well I'm
living rent-free in your head you know
and and and to really take some sort of
pleasure in it it didn't last for me
because it didn't come naturally to me
so I couldn't stay like that for very
long but I did try it and what I can say
is that thriving on hatred is as bad as
being hateful yourself it's probably
worse really to actually enjoy it it's
it's a sick demented thing but there are
a lot of people in that camp
that's a mistake the third mistake is
the mistake that I settled on
for a long time which is to be numb to
it
I'm very guilty of this third mistake
of you know
afraid of the hatred and not enjoying it
either but just feeling nothing
much of the time
and I think most people think this is
the right approach you hear people all
the time declare oh I don't care what
anyone thinks I don't care but I don't
care what anyone thinks and we sometimes
will confuse this attitude with strength
well thinking well that's what it means
to be strong is to not care what anyone
thinks right isn't that what we always
say well you shouldn't care what the
world thinks don't care about it don't
care about their opinions
but that's not strict
if you really don't care it's kind of
like a sociopath who has literally no
fear or emotion at all cannot be
courageous even when he puts himself in
harm's way because fear is an element of
courage courage is feeling the fear and
acting anyway if you have no fear
whatsoever then you cannot be courageous
even if you're doing something that
looks courageous you're only doing it
because you don't have that reaction
that natural human reaction of fear so
being numb to the opinions of the world
and being numb to the hatred well that
doesn't make you strong that actually
makes you weak that means that you've
been worn down and beaten down and now
you're just sort of this flat line of
not feeling anything what I've realized
is
for after a long time of kind of taking
this approach of saying well I really
don't care what people think
either even if I even if 50,000 people
are saying the worst things about me I
really don't care what they think
I feel nothing
after a while I realized that
you know doesn't seem right I think I
should care what they think
I should feel something
now the things shouldn't be fear
it shouldn't be pleasure either on the
other end of it but
I should feel something right
doesn't seem right to feel nothing I
mean how can you feel nothing
how could he have swarms of angry people
shouting at you and feel nothing that
doesn't seem human
and what I've realized is well I mean
look at look at what the Bible says
those who persecute you turn the other
cheek
so that's what we should feel we should
feel move to pray for them we should
feel pity for them
so we should care because not because we
care what they think in the sense that
we want to we want them to like us so
we're gonna adjust our opinions to make
them care or to make them like us but
when people hate us I think we should
care for their own sake because their
wallowing and stewing in this hatred and
we should pity them for that
pray for those who persecute you turn
the other cheek we tend to gloss over
these parts of Christ's teachings but
we'll be glut we grow up we basically
gloss over everything is it but
especially stuff like this
we gloss over it because it's become
kind of a cliche we've heard it so often
especially turn the other cheek we heard
so often it's become just kind of the
part of the vocabulary part of the
language and it's become a cliche that's
the worst thing really that can ever
happen to the Bible is when it becomes a
cliche when we turn it into that which
is what we've done if we really were to
if we really thought about it
if we didn't gloss over it and we really
confronted these teachings turn the
other cheek pray for those who persecute
you we would see that these are radical
really challenging commands that Jesus
is giving us really I mean this it's it
seems almost crazy turn the other cheek
what pray for people who are attacking
me pray for them
I think most people although we would we
look at that and we say oh yeah sure
return the other cheek yeah that's great
advice thanks Jesus thanks for that
advice and we'll say aw yeah I do that
all the time now definitely sure sure I
think if we were to be honest we might
we may look at our own lives and realize
that we have never turned the other
cheek
we have never prayed for those who
persecute us I realize at a certain
point I realized that I looked at it and
I said you know what I don't think I've
ever I got all these people attack me I
don't think I've ever prayed for them
ever
I'd like to think that I have but I
don't think I ever really have
now
part of the issue with there with with
this with these aspects of Christ's
teaching is that they seem at first
glance to be kind of in contradiction
they seem to contradict other things
that he said because this is also the
same Jesus who famously fashioned a whip
out of cords and drove the money
changers out of the temple flipping over
tables this was vandalism and assault he
was assaulting people with a whip and
turning over tables I mean it's this is
it's a crime what he did right um this
is also the same Jesus who says I did
not come to bring peace but a sword
dividing families this is the same Jesus
who said that I wish you were either
hots or cold and because you're lukewarm
I spit you out of my mouth but Luke
lukewarm is sin in it as a synonym for
mild but other points it seems like he's
telling us to be mild but not lukewarm
telling us to turn the other cheek but
yet over here he's flipping tables and
using a whip I mean it's just it seems
like how do you make sense of all of it
and you realize that you make sense of
it this way then what Jesus is saying is
when you personally are being attacked
when your own personal honor
is being assaulted or questioned
that's when you turn the other cheek
um
that's when you don't respond with this
kind of force right when it's when you
personally are the victim
but when God is being attacked when your
faith is being attacked when we're
dealing with heresy and sacrilege and
blasphemy
when when truth is being attacked even
when your family is being attacked well
that's that's different
then we are supposed to rise up and
respond with force respond vocally even
even respond even be militant in our
defense of God's on end of truth and
virtue and of good and holy things
now we we tend to get this we tend to
get this backwards I think
a lot of times what we'll do is we'll
see the world attacking God and our
faith and truth and committing the
sacrilege and heresy and blasphemy and
that's when we say oh we'll turn the
other cheek be the bigger man
but then when when that when that when
the when the hyenas when the pack of
hyenas move on from there to us and they
start personally sniping at us that's
when all of a sudden we're not so
willing to turn the other cheek and and
and that's when we want to rise up in
defense of ourselves but it's supposed
to be the opposite because that is
strength
strength is
being willing to
you know
put yourself in the midst of it
and to to jump in
to defend these things that are beyond
you and above you and are bigger than
you
but when it comes to personal hatred and
personal persecution and people coming
after you personally that's when we're
not supposed to muddy ourselves by
flinging mud at the mud slingers or
debase ourselves by trying to defend our
own personal honor the people who don't
really care about our honor anyway so
there's no point
forceful and vocal in our defense of
God's honor and of truth and virtue but
when it comes to personal attacks
personal insults personal affront to
those to those specifically Christ says
turn the other cheek that's what a
strong man does he doesn't cry
he doesn't snicker like a little troll
and find some perverse pleasure in it he
isn't morally exhausted and numb instead
he's resolute he's confident and he's
uninterested in getting involved in
bickering or back-and-forth and
when people personally insult him he
just
he's not gonna get down there and try to
say no I'm not that
I'm not stupid you're stupid
week that's childish
but he does feel something like I said
he feels pity for his attackers he feels
sorry for them
he sees how pathetic the whole scene is
how miserable these people are how empty
their lives are and he prays for them he
prays sincerely for them
and Christ gives us the perfect example
of this approach of course during his
passion
Father forgive them for they know not
what they do he said that while he was
nailed to a cross an unbearable agony
and we're never going to attain that
level of heroism and selflessness well
we could still follow it and use it as a
model and I think that many of us have
never really tried this but it is
possible to pray for those who attack
you and I'm still like I said I am NOT
the perfect model of this whatsoever so
I don't put myself forth and say do what
I'm doing instead let's do what Jesus
does but I am trying and what I found is
you know for me right now most of the
time
when I get personally attacked if I'm
personally attack
and if I turn around and pray for the
person attacking me
the prayer that I'm saying silently in
my head is not 100% sincere I want it to
be sincere but it's not because I'm
still ticked off at the guy
but I'm at least right now I'm just at
the point I'm at the very beginning I'm
just trying to form the habit anyway I'm
trying to develop at least the habit of
being attacked and the first thing is to
respond by praying for the person
and so right now it's it's not 100%
sincere I'm still it's very novice level
stuff
but I think that's what we have to do a
lot of times in life is even if your
heart's not in it even if you're not
feeling it do the right thing anyway
do the right thing lead with your
actions you know
um go through the motions at least in
the beginning
and then eventually your heart will
start to change along with it
especially when God sees you putting in
the effort and really try
it's like it's not enough to be really
you know to be good to be good people
I don't think we can leap all the way
there first we have to really desire to
be good
and to do the right thing
we have to at least what we have to do
if that maybe we need to desert we have
to want to want to be good you have to
want to want to do the the right thing I
think that's the first step
and once we take that first step then
hopefully the rest will follow so right
now I'm trying to develop the habit and
so when people ask me how do I deal with
the haters I guess the real answer is
I'm working on it
we could all you know work on this
together because the other thing is look
last thing I'll say is it's it's the
only thing that works anyway
you know this is also good practical
advice like so much in the Bible
these are moral truths moral commands
but also on top of it it's it's just
good solids it is also good practical
advice for how to live it isn't merely
that we can't turn the Bible into merely
a collection of life advice you know so
it's not just that but it is also that
so when it comes to personal attacks
it's like there's nothing else you can
do anyway when people are personally
insulting you to get down in the mud
with them and to try to defend yourself
it's just a no matter what that's the
head that's how insults work that's sort
of the point of them is that no matter
what you say once you're insulted
personally no matter what you say to
defend yourself against that insult it's
only going to end up reinforcing
whatever the insult was
so there's no point
it might as well just take the higher
approach that Jesus is prescribing for
us
because on top of being the right
approach it's also the only one that
works
alright thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening and have a great
day I'll talk to you tomorrow Godspeed